every human being lives off the death of
some other life form from the Tree of
Life okay that's right the only
exceptions are milk and honey which
don't require killing that's saying I
never put that together that Moses is
trying to go to the promised land the
land of milk and honey these would be
the foods that are non-dual they're not
life living eating death yeah I don't
know how much the Bible thought about
that in advance of writing it but it is
these two Foods what's interesting of
course is veganism
is expressly excludes milk and honey
that's right from their diet interesting
this is what's amazing to me okay but
the two foods that don't involve killing
anybody any that no but eat the
reproductive organs of the plants